The Joe Rogan experience.
Do you have guys trash talk you
like you're pretty easy going guy.
Easy going. It's nothing to my face.
It's always subtle. If, if I ever
hear about anybody saying something,
it's just through word of mouth
and I'm just like, yeah, well,
but you never had like a Conor McGregor
type incident were only only in the
beginning with Paul Craig.
But I think it was just,
it was just like his thing. We've
like, we smashed that beef, you know?
Yeah. But what do you think about
trash talking in this day and age?
Because in many ways it looked,
Connor's an amazing fighter
and his fighting skills,
what's made him such an
international superstar,
but he also talks some mad shit and that
helped him too because he was so good
at it. It was funny. He would say funny,
mean insulting Shit. It was fucking great.
100% yeah. But I think what
people forget, Joe, is that like,
that's always been Connor,
even when you go and, and, and,
and look at the,
the,
the interviews from before he was
a in the UFC and he was just like,
I'm going to make a bunch of money
and I'm going to be all this.
And so like he created
that for himself and yeah,
he made a bunch of money from talking
trash because he always had a plan that
that's was, that's what
he was going to do. Yeah.
And so I think people try to hop on it
just to sell tickets or get money and
sometimes it works,
it gets people wanting to watch and it
gets your name up and stuff like that.
But that's not the time.
But name I want to make for myself.
Like I don't like people
talking trash to me.
So I'm not really gonna talk trash to
anybody unless there's something that's
really personal. But if I don't
know you and I don't care about you,
then I don't really consider it.
Like why would I talk trash?
I don't even care about you.
It's a waste of energy.
It's a waste of their,
like I got so much other
stuff to care about her on.
Yeah, it's, well, it's a very
healthy look man. I mean the way you,
you're seeing like that you said healthy,
like I like to maintain a healthy heart
and mind as much as possible students.
Damn man. Like mental health is a
real thing, you know what I mean?
And especially like,
especially just having certain obligations
and and just using social media and
having people reach out and they say
like, oh ignore this, ignore that.
But it's like, man, it's like, it's hard
to just ignore certain things, you know,
like you still see things then.
So just that and condition of the
world and just everything man,
being in multiple different countries
and here in this news and that news and
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Like for a person who like,
who wants to care about the world,
they're just genuinely cares like a lock
and go on in my mind. So I'm just like,
ah,
I don't even want that in my heart now.
I'm just going to do my best to
kind of keep my own peace and, uh,
come fight time.
I let it loose.
[inaudible].